hello guys i am super excited to present
to you
our latest two bedroom environment in
chester come on in let me show you how
it looks
so this is the living room the guy did
an amazing job with the
furnishing the apartment as you can see
they've already
set up the table and everything is ready
to go forward and
our next guest let me show you the
bedrooms
i am super pleased on how this bedroom
looks will look like
there are two double beds with amazing
bedding but at the same time they have a
beautiful view
hey what's up guys welcome back to my
channel i am sat here with a
wonderful lady called amelia she's
become financially free
through property she's quit her
full-time job she came from romania
into the uk about four years ago
couldn't speak a word
of english and what she's achieved is
fantastic and who she's become
is fantastic she's become a really close
friend a massive asset
to the academy just finished the 12
months on the academy
and amelia how's it been well first of
all thank you for having me samuel
it's been an absolute blessing i'm 100
a product of the academy the network and
the environment that i found there
definitely developed me to the person
that i am today
and i couldn't be grateful enough for
what i found there
in terms of people but in the same time
in terms of the technicality behind the
uh property investing side of it so
it's been crazy it's been crazy and
something that you said to me as well as
you said when you first
obviously you couldn't speak any english
when you first came into the country a
few years back
but when you were doing viewings and
they were talking about like
certain terminology and you were like
what like double glazing
and things what was that like so when i
came to the uk
um i could understand what people were
were talking about around me
but i couldn't put like a phrase
together so it was
a bit difficult in the first year or two
to start
um speaking properly and find my words
when i wanted to
to say something uh and then like in the
next
two years once um once i started to
speak a little bit better and
my vocabulary started to to become to
grow and become a little bit better
um i ended up in a new job coming to
um to the crash course and
i i went to do my first viewing and
obviously there were
there were so many things that i was
supposed to to learn in the property
word and
first first things that um
came to mind was when when i was doing
the the viewing with the builder and he
was just
showing me the guttering um how the
how the the windows are supposed to look
like and they're supposed to be double
placed and all the technical
uh behind the scenes for uh for a brr as
i remember going home and just like
googling every single word that
i've heard or just trying to find all
the words in the br course
uh to kind of get my head around
everything
so i was learning english
as i was doing viewings and yeah i've
got to a point where now i i can
i can feel very comfortable in having a
conversation with
with anyone about about everything it's
it's been definitely um
a time where i've managed to to grow a
lot
to learn a lot and i couldn't be
grateful enough because well that's all
about if you're not growing you're dying
aren't you
absolutely and it's funny because even
people who are fluent english speakers
even i sometimes obviously the builders
are talking their jargon
and and people like what so i can only
imagine what it's like when english is
your second language and you're quite
new into the country
but you know you need to kind of be very
true to yourself uh
because i know where where i'm at and
i'm just at the point where i said you
know what i'm sorry i
i don't understand that can you please
explain to me or
what does that word uh would you mind
uh telling me more about it and things
like this people are so friendly and
they can't wait to help you
to explain uh more things about it and i
don't think that it's a case
of me not being able to understand
english it's just me going into an area
that i've never been before and i'm
pretty sure that is the same for any
other english
person that is trying to do the same
thing because if i'm taking someone
that's
20 years old and take
a data person to a viewing he'll
probably don't know the technicality
behind
the behind the scenes so it's a learning
curve for
everyone who wants to do something good
something new but you just need to
embrace the challenge and grow with it
correct and another thing is as well
is you've been one of my most favorite
students
on the academy because you ask the right
questions and if you're not sure about
something you'll ask the question
so what was the crash course like when
you first came and was it as expected
what happened
i absolutely loved it so um i went to
the crash course probably
two years ago it was two summers uh ago
summer 2019. yes yeah um it was in
birmingham
uh there were a lot of a lot of people
there
a lot of energy i'm well i'm normally a
very
energetic person so i wanted to be in
the front row just like
asking questions paying attention to
what everyone was saying
it was very interesting because like my
brother went to the crash course
before me and he said you need to kind
of go and
uh see uh see this guy because you're
gonna love it
and you're gonna get a lot of free
information from the crash course
but just make sure you don't buy the
courses
and obviously at the end of the the
crash course i went on the
on the dfe because for me it was um
a no-brainer i wanted the
i wanted the information i wanted the
environment and everything that
uh was there was exactly what i was
i was looking for so interesting though
that he said that so he said go on the
crash course
but don't pay for any further courses
and
and when you went in your mind were you
thinking
i'm not going to pay for any further
courses or were you open no i'm not like
with me i always say yes to any
opportunity that
comes across i review whatever stands in
front of me
if it's for me i'll take it on if it's
not then i'll pass it
and at that point in time uh i've like
i've had a very um
direct assessment of it like i i've
genuinely looked at
all the cards at the table is this
something that
uh it's suitable for me and it's gonna
help me grow
and the answer for me was yes so i said
yes i'm gonna take it
to the next level so it was something
that i was interested
in and it just made sense for me that's
great and again
you're an open-minded person but you're
also a free thinker
you're a critical thinker you're
unafraid to make decisions
um i want to talk a little bit about
shortly about the decision of leaving
your job
and going full time into property which
i know is a very very hard decision
but before we get there you went to the
deal finally extravaganza
there was a lot of people what happened
uh
so the dfe was the point where
i've seen that everything is possible it
was a
room full of investors deal sourcers
people that had
renterans had hmos had essays
everything was happening in that room um
and it just opened my eyes because when
you see it happening in front of you and
you connect with so many people you
can't go
back so like my mind was expanded to new
dimensions
during the the dfe and i just couldn't
go back to a normal life
after after that and just because you've
seen
that it's possible and you were having
people saying you know what i'm a
property investor i have this kind of
money and i'm looking for someone to
help me
find the properties because i don't have
enough time to
to look into things uh myself or
you're finding people that have
rent rent service accommodation and
it was so much business happening in
that room uh
that i decided to join the academy and i
said well
if it's possible for everyone here why
wouldn't
it be possible for for me yeah that's
awesome
and throughout the last um 18 months of
working with you on the academy
your name comes up all the time
everybody is always talking about emilia
doing business with amelia and honestly
not only have you been a great student
but you've also been a massive
asset to the academy so i'm really
grateful
to have had you as a student and now a
friend
and you've you've i mean how would you
say
we'll go on to the finances but how
would you say you've grown as a person
over the last 18 so months was a very
very
uh shy person i was just keeping myself
to myself
at the dfe i've actually met one of the
the academy members one of my favorite
people's like a big brother to me
um and he saw that like
there's uh you're a very hard-working
person
um you're taking action you're going out
and doing viewings and he started to
look
uh after me and every single time i've
met someone from
from the academy i've um i've gave
all the information that i have and they
the same so like
we're like a family i can't be grateful
enough for for everyone that
i've met in their beautiful people with
beautiful hearts
uh business-minded people as well and
um um what can i say
it's it's it's been a journey that
took me from a very shy
person to um to a businesswoman that can
stay in front of a developer and say
look this is the deal do you want it or
not um
and whenever there's
uh there's change i will always say
if you have an opportunity to to change
something to do something different
take it and see where it takes because
that's what i've done i've always tried
to change things put myself in a
different situation
uncomfortable or not but i've always
tried to change something so i can
grow to the to the next level and the
academy for me
it was the best decision that uh
that i've ever taken it's
it's been a journey from a personal
point of view from a business point of
view
the things that um i've seen i've
learned the people that i've i've met
i just can't be grateful enough for for
the whole network that
you've you've provided for us it's it's
a true blessing i i genuinely saying
this
it i don't think that there's any other
place in the uk or
even in romania where i've met so many
good hearted people
um with a similar mindset and it just
helps us grow to the next level we're
pushing each other i'm actually in the
accountability group i'm not going to
say their names but they know who they
are they're like my favorite people
ever and we're challenging ourselves and
give
us like a task well you know what you're
supposed to do this
to to grow to the next uh stage i know
you're afraid
of that so why don't you just like push
against that
fear and see what comes out of it and it
just
helps us uh grow to the next level so
that's what we're doing as part of the
network
but um the life courses
is um is taking you to the next step as
well you do get the technicality
but the trainers help you to definitely
go
uh on the on the next level from a
personal low point of view they do a lot
of exercises with you
um the things that you learn there
it just your mind definitely gets
expanded to a dimension and then
to a new dimension and we'll never go go
back to
where it was again that's absolutely
amazing and i really appreciate you
saying so it's really rewarding
for me because i'm a small i feel like a
small part
of the academy because the academy is
not just about me at all
and sometimes people might think before
it's actually a community
it's a entire community and there's lots
of training programs there's lots of
mentors there's lots of trainers there's
lots of people
and i think it's really important that
you be in that kind of environment
because if you're in an environment of
winners then you'll be a winner
if you're surrounding yourself with
losers then you'll be a loser
100. um so of all the training courses
because there's lots which one was maybe
some of your favorites
uh so i have two favorites on personal
development side of you and two
favorites on like the technicality bits
on personal uh uh development was
uh bobby yeah and tell the world
those were the the trainings that
definitely
i don't want to say it broke me down but
it definitely
uh took me in um
in a place within myself where i
couldn't go there by my own
so with the help of who was in the
training and the trainers
i was able to kind of discover things
about me that i didn't know before
um and obviously from there
uh grow to the to the next level from a
technical point of view
obviously the essay course and the brr
ones
yeah like you find um
the best uh the best strategies
to increase your cash flow how to
recycle money
uh you see a little bit more on the um
vr side of it just not uh a quick refurb
you kind of
get a feeling into development what
what you can do more with with a house
than just a normal
uh vitality or a normal reverb yeah and
you
have become a bit of an expert in
property
and i mean with sir you've got how many
service accommodation property units
uh at the moment standard they're in my
name so you've got 10
in your name and that's a combination of
different types of deals
they're all structured slightly
differently and some of them are making
more money than others
but overall how how are they going
uh so these 10 units um
the first unit that i've got was uh back
in uh
in december um there were the the
manchester uh
deals um at the beginning
obviously the first uh two months with
service accommodation is always
a little bit tougher until you get um
you get your property advertised when
you get the reviews the algorithm
pops you up and you just need to be able
to be patient
until um until your property gets
marketed properly yeah so now we're in a
point where
with six of them uh we're i'm getting
around 2 300 pounds uh
a month profit right so that was six six
of them which were the initial six that
you took on
yes i'm making about 2 300 is that clean
profit per month
well that's amazing i mean that's like a
full-time salary
well that's that was the plan with them
when i've
put my resignation in uh i wanted
something really fast to to bring some
income in
to make sure that it's paying my bills
so i can uh grow my own
uh sa business so the other four that i
have
uh are managed by me with my own essay
management uh
company wow so so okay so you started
off
by using tapping into other people's
management systems and things like that
exactly got your first six got some bit
of cash flow
2 300 saw it was working handed your
notice in
and then since then you've gone on to um
manage
set up your own service accommodation
management company exactly so you're
finding your own deals you're managing
your own properties and now which is
really exciting is
you're even managing other people's
properties on top of your town
yes which we'll get onto which is
incredible when this all started
happening
talk to me about the decision to quit
your job
because i know that was not an easy one
uh everything
happened at still the world back in uh
in november
uh that was the point where i've seen
that there are bigger and better things
out there
for for people to go after their
purposes
uh than just being in a normal uh in a
normal job
and tell the where was the point where i
said you know what after this program
i cannot go back to a normal life
to my um uh to my job i absolutely loved
the
the people that i work with i absolutely
loved uh my job
is i'm a management system engineer i'm
accredited auditor i put systems in
place for automotive factories from like
when the idea gets developed until the
product
gets out of the door so i'm basically
handling all that way of working for
for a factory and audit them at the end
i've loved it it's it's very interesting
process
you get the opportunity to work with all
the departments you have the opportunity
to add the
value to see that people are getting
happier when you
develop the the processes and things
like this
you get a lot of significance because
obviously it's
um it's a job that you
where you are one of the key players in
the company
and it gave me it it ticked a lot of
boxes for me so
it was a very big decision for me to say
you know what i'm quitting a very secure
job
where i'm getting a lot of significance
i'm getting very nice very nice money
i love everyone that i work with and
i'm just gonna put this aside and jump
into
a very unknown word uh the property word
uh but if it weren't for the academy
members to
hold my hand and say you know you know
what whatever happens we're here
we're gonna be with you all the all the
way
and we're going to make sure that you're
not going to get left behind
and you're going to be successful with
with all of us
if it weren't for the academy members
and everyone who
stood behind me to push me to say no no
no
you need to do this because you are made
for
bigger and better things
and we would love to kind of see what
you can become in property if you
if you take the drum and because of that
kind of
support and what happened during the
tell the world
um i have taken that that decision was
very very hard because it felt like i'm
going to a heartbreak
and my notice period was of
um it was three months long so it wasn't
something that happened quick and i was
just like okay i'm gonna forget about it
it was
three months of oh god i'm quitting this
job i'm leaving all of these people and
they've done everything they could
to to keep me there they've uh they've
offered me more money
well everything that i would have wanted
from that job
it it has been offered to me and i had
to say no
because i just wanted uh to do
something bigger and better with my life
that
can potentially impact more people
i would love to be in a position where i
can help others to
to get to to where i'm at uh now
and just serve in the way that
i've been served and you know help
people in the way that i've been helped
if if it weren't for this environment
and this group of people
i would never have been where i'm now
and um doing what i'm doing
and i would love to give back in the
same way that i've received from from
the community
well you do and now you come down and
you crew at the events
and i mean i see massive
uh future ahead of you i know you're
just getting started in fact
those six properties that were making
you about 2 300
since quitting your job what month did
you quit your job march
march you've taken another four
properties yeah
and how are they how are they going um
so
three of them went live two two and a
half weeks ago
in the first week we had bookings worth
of 15 000 pounds
like advanced bookings for all three of
them
um we've done a lot of market research
before
taking them on they're very close to old
trafford the stadium very close to the
lorry and we've seen
um some signs in the market that we can
have very good rates on those apartments
and we have we have bookings in
july and august for a weekend worth of
a thousand one hundred when the events
are
are on um they're constantly
getting bookings worth of 600 pounds
um a weekend the one that is like a
three bedroom one
uh and it's been crazy to see that
um if you follow the the rules and
everything that you've been
taught in the in the trainings is
actually gonna work and with the
manchester deals
uh it's ticked every single box that
we've learned uh in the in the course
and
when you are out there and actually
doing it it's very important to kind of
have the confidence to take so much risk
and so much uh responsibility
i've had other deals that i've um
passed on and i said no because it
didn't take all the boxes
yeah and i think it's very important to
get the
to to do the market research before you
take on
big projects like like i do now yeah and
again this is
like i always say it's a process not a
journey
100 is not no it's not something that's
going to happen overnight it didn't
happen for me overnight i've had
at least a year of learning all the
strategy
until i've come to a point where i can
combine deal sourcing with
service accommodation with a little bit
of vrr and things like this
one of the last unit that i've got we're
doing a small
refurb on it until it goes uh on the
market so it's a bit of your or a little
bit of
yeah because you've got to take the
skills the refurb bits
um so the service accommodation units
that you've got which are
rent to rents yeah so you've combined
rent to rent service accommodation and
delivery strategies but
how much profit roughly per month with
all of all of the ten i know some of
them are quite new
but are you projected to make on a
monthly basis in profit
uh so we're looking at normally at least
500 pounds
a unit they have potential to go
more than that but being conservative
we're saying that at least 500 pounds
a unit is something that
we would be happy with we've seen
profits bigger than that
smaller than that it just depends on
where the unit is and the time of the
year sure now in manchester for example
uh during the summer time we're seeing
very good bookings the ones that i have
done south
uh they're extremely profitable uh we
had
for three days uh bookings worth of 700
pounds so like crazy
crazy money uh but in the same time
there are others that
make less than 500 pounds it just
depends on
the area on the time of the year what
kind of
people are in here and things like this
and it's very good to have your
portfolio spread it out because you kind
of spread the risk
and you can get the best out of the
whole uk market
yeah so 500 pounds per month
conservatively
but being being reasonably averaging out
because it depends month by month
so on 10 units are you talking about a
profit of about five
thousand pounds across the portfolio
going directly to you
it's not it's something like that but
how does that make you feel though
um i i genuinely don't see the money
because
everything that i've been learning and
went back into the business into the
next unit
doing the next project and things like
that right so what you're saying is the
profit
instead of spending fancy things you're
reinvestigating to
buy more houses doing more deals exactly
which is smart
because you're scaling so the last one
that we've done
none of this properties were ever done
with my own money we've
either leveraged money from uh
from previous deals or
we've raised finance for for them so the
more
the more i'm growing the more money i'm
putting in the next stage
of the of the business what about
because on top of that
you're also deal sourcing yes so talk to
me about the figures because
i know you focus a lot on your personal
growth
and your happiness and stuff like that
but it's important as well to look at
the
results yeah and and the two go hand in
hand
because the more you the more you grow
as a person the more money you're gonna
make and the more your bank will grow
how's the deal sourcing going uh so
since uh since march
um since where i've started to be
full-time in property
i've done uh 16 and a half thousand
pounds
in india sourcing wow uh
yeah that's incredible it was
it was very nice to kind of see the
money coming into the account and then
going out into the next project
yeah um but at least you can see that
it's working and you know that
uh like the decision that you've made it
was uh it was worth it
are you glad that you quit your job uh
yes i am but there's i can't say that i
can't say that it's been a very
easy easy journey like being a property
entrepreneur and investing in property
is definitely not
an easy job it's very very stressful and
handling
um deadlines projects everything that
goes
wrong is definitely more stressful than
what i've had before
more rewarding 100 and uh i'm definitely
looking forward to see like what the
future uh holds for me because this is
only only the beginning yeah i'm 100
uh happy that i've quit my uh my job
because i can see that
uh there are a lot of opportunities out
there and i'm excited about them
uh but in the same time i know that it's
like that the responsibility that i'm
taking it's quite big
and yeah we'll see where it goes yeah
and it's still quite
early days it is you spent a year and a
half training
and then you got a few deals quit your
job now the money is coming in
but you've now got all the
responsibilities of running a business
and you are a business owner now so
how does it feel to be a business owner
um
i think i can't say that i'm i'm feeling
any different from
how it felt before because wherever i've
worked
my work ethic is in a way that
i'm considering that business being or
treating it as
being my own business and that's why
i've always been so
um highly appreciated wherever i worked
because i've taken full responsibility
of what's what's happening around me and
i was treating
those workplaces as their being my
businesses
yeah uh and the only difference now
is just uh everything comes towards me
there's no filtering system or
someone else that's going to deal with
all the problems it's just
it's just me it feels very excited it
feels very
um powerful because
well you're the person that is in charge
of
of everything definitely um
and very very exciting let me ask you a
question then
you say it's been a lot of hard work
which is true because being an
entrepreneur especially when you're
starting with no money or very little
money
and you're having to grow a business
from scratch um it comes with
late nights and deadlines and things
what is your strongest reason why
what why why are you doing this
um in in my
mid twenties uh i've had some like
health
issues problems uh and i couldn't take a
day off
to to deal with it so i had to go
through some procedures and
um the day after i had to go
back to work um and
the fact that i couldn't take the time
off to deal with
it to see my friends my family because
it was quite
uh quite intense what was happening
there
um it made me realize that
if i'm not doing things now to take care
of myself
and be secure from a financial point of
view
i might end up in 10 or 20 years when
something like this might happen again
and well i'm not gonna be in a position
where
i'm financially um
well enough to take care of myself and
all my
bills and things like this to
go and take some time off so that's one
of the uh
the biggest reasons why i'm being so
driven
to make sure that um
no matter what happens with me um
i'll be able to kind of have that time
off uh
secondly it's because i've been to a
place where
uh it felt very lonely and
[Music]
the environment and all the love and
support that i received from
from the academy made me a different
person than i am today and i just want
to give back the love and support that
i've received there and those are the
two two biggest reasons why i'm doing
what i'm doing because
i can't be grateful enough from what for
what i found here
and i just want to give back in the same
way that i received
that's awesome and you know what a lot
of people ask me
why do i bother running a training
business
if i'm if i've got such a successful
property development business and i've
got all these properties giving me this
income
why don't i just retire on a beach and
sometimes people can't understand
until they're making money as well and
then
actually you realize that wait it's not
all about the money
no it's not definitely it's not and
i just want to like uh put my head on
the pillow and say you know what i gave
it my all
and i just want to do something bigger
and better with the whitish wrap than
just having a normal life and going to
the pub
i'm 100 sure that um
where we're made for for bigger things
and if anyone
if anyone could uh follow their own
purposes and
uh do what they're supposed to to do
uh in this world we could have so much
more
happiness so much more money around us
uh and i can't say that it would be a
renaissance alert or something like that
but
can you imagine if anyone everyone would
do what they're supposed to do what kind
of
people we would have around us and i i
would i would be blessed to kind of see
something like that yeah but that's
well i am very very proud of what you've
done
and i'm also very very excited about
your future i know
there's big things coming you know much
much much bigger than anybody
could imagine so you know massive
congratulations on all that you've
achieved
what would be your final words of advice
to someone listening to this interview
what would you say to them maybe
if you were talking to yourself two
years ago
i would say say yes to every single
opportunity that comes
towards you done the things on your own
make sure you have the right people
around you
and be open for what
what the future holds holds for you
and 100 don't do things on your own uh
get the uh get the training you get
the people around you that can can
support you along
along the way samuel 365 is a great
platform where you can find
this kind of business oriented people
with a great heart and i can't
uh i can't say how amazing these people
uh are that's awesome well amelia thank
you so much for coming on the show
guys i hope you've been inspired by
amelia's story
i know i'm feeling inspired so drop a
like on the video
if you've got questions for amelia then
you can drop them in the comment box
below or
join samuel 365 community you can join
for a pound
for the first seven days and then it's
95 pounds a month where you can network
with people like amelia myself and
others
that are doing property deals that are
full-time in property that are
financially free
if you want to watch a playlist of over
100
interviews just like this winners on our
wednesday playlist
watch more interviews and be inspired if
you want to
subscribe to the channel you can do that
over here
and if you want to join me at the
property investors crash course or on
samuel 365
i'll leave links in the description
below and i hope to see you real soon
thanks for watching
god bless